if I showed you two big intersections
one with a bunch of signs traffic lights
and boundaries and one with no markings
or apparent rules at all which one would
look safer to you towns all over Europe
are starting to experiment with streets
like this where cars bikes buses and
people can travel freely in the same
space I think this looks like an
accident waiting to happen but I know
someone who would know a lot more about
this than I do I'm Roman Mara's from 99%
invisible and that's what urban planners
often refer to as a shared space design
strategy it seems counterintuitive but
there's evidence that getting rid of all
signs and barriers might make our
streets a lot safer so how does it work
there's a spot in Google Street View
where you can witness a town undergoing
this exact transformation this is point
in England about 20 minutes away from
Manchester here's the city centre in May
2011 there's a mess of signs and lights
a few small sidewalks and some half
hazard guardrails to keep pedestrians
safe and here it is in July 2015
traffic lights road signs curbs all gone
something very strange is happening on
the streets of Britain a know if you've
noticed but in some places pavements and
roads have been blurring into one with
cars buses and pedestrians all share in
the same space the town spent 4 million
pounds to expand sidewalk space and
strip the city centre of traditional
demarcations now the only marker left is
this little sign pointing shared space
village the concept is that the absence
of separation will make everyone more
cautious so commuters slow down make eye
contact and negotiate watch what happens
when a boy in pointen is encouraged to
cross the street without waiting for the
cars to clear the intersection
because cars don't spend time waiting at
traffic lights it takes less time on
average for them to get through the
crossing
even when bikers and pedestrians are
absent cars drive slow due to a concept
called edge friction it's the idea that
nearby vertical elements in a driver's
peripheral vision like trees or lamps
create a visual cue for how fast they're
going on a highway those are often
totally absent so the sidelines blur in
a shared space those lines play an
important mental trick to slow down
drivers in theory shared space works
well for pedestrians allowing them to
follow their desired path while walking
instead of being limited to a strict
path they can walk exactly in the
direction they want to go in practice
that doesn't always seem to be the case
video footage of a shared space at Elric
square in Ashford England shows that
pedestrians mostly still stick to
crosswalks or where a crosswalk would be
that's largely because these layouts are
stressful the majority of a survey group
asked about crossing Elvis Square
reported feeling anxious about it and
those pedestrians frequently report that
they prefer things the way they used to
be but the way things used to be is
relative if you look at old footage of
city streets in the early 1900's cars
mixed freely with pedestrians bicyclists
and street cars vehicles couldn't go
very fast back then so there wasn't a
huge concern about separating them from
walkers and bikers with plenty of city
streets that's still the case without
any intentional urban planning but the
big question is whether these
deliberately strip down designs actually
make people safer it seems that in many
cases they do for one thing we know that
the number of accidents drops after
shared spaces are installed in Ipswich
rates of accidents involving injuries
fell from 23 over three years to just
one per year in London's Kensington High
Street the number of pedestrians injured
dropped by nearly 60% and in drachten
and the Netherlands accidents at one
intersection fell from 36 and four years
to two in two years we also know that
shared spaces are quantifiably more
free-flowing based on analysis of
traffic on
flex with video footage like this from
exhibition Road in London analysts can
rate the severity of a traffic conflict
based on the participants speed and
change of course before the shared space
renovation one pedestrian had to step
back onto the sidewalk to avoid a
departing car
another broke out into a sprint to avoid
getting hit by an oncoming van after the
shared space installation traffic
conflicts were less frequent and less
severe on average like this where
pedestrians wait for a cab to cross
before continuing or this one where a
cyclist changes course to avoid
pedestrians but that doesn't mean these
designs work for everyone it's the most
ludicrous idea I've ever heard what
about blind people from the beginning
shared space designs have been under
fire for providing insufficient
protections for disabled pedestrians
especially the visually impaired the
family of a pensioner who died a month
after being hit by a bus have called for
traffic lights to be reinstalled at the
junction traffic lights here were
recently removed to make way for a
so-called shared space but it's a move
which has angered David's family I'm
sure if the traffic lights were there
this would have happened
a 2015 House of Lords report called for
a temporary ban on shared space designs
and in August 2016 a select committee of
the House of Commons launched an inquiry
into the accessibility of such
environments their final report in April
2017 asked the government to put all
shared space schemes on hold until they
improved the process of consulting
disabled communities preliminary designs
like these by the Danish Building
Research Institute give us an idea of
what that balance might look like they
include both the mixed traffic of shared
space and the raised street textures and
button activated crosswalks that
disabled users are used to shared spaces
can be effective but for this kind of
plan to work across communities it will
require a lot more research to determine
what will work in different places and
what will serve the needs of all the
people sharing the streets
[Music]
you